I believe in education more than
anything on Earth I don't believe in the
way that it's sold in 2022. I love
talking about college might not be the
answer so I get tons of feedback from
parents but for the first seven years of
that content it was all [ __ ] you Gary
get out of my kids scream you're [ __ ]
up my child's life in the last three
years it's been like you've really
helped my family like we've actually had
different conversations with our kids
and things are happening so I've always
struggled with the way education is
packaged and sold in the world but the
most important thing in the world is
education I'm not here to hurt feelings
if you're an educator if you're a parent
that's ideology is like College college
I have so much empathy for that I know
if you're a lawyer and a doctor good
let's keep that go to school for that
you're right I don't want a doctor who
never went to school working on me
you're absolutely right the problem is
there's like six of those things what
about everybody else right I think we
have to understand that every single
human is different and if we don't
reverse engineer whether good or bad at
and they have to go through One Singular
system it's inconceivable that we're
doing anything good for them